I just want to um talk about this uh
State of the Union I think
um Putin made recently oh yeah you know
it's a two-minute video I shared it on
my Twitter thread you guys can go pull
it up if you want but you know here's
some highlights I'm not going to read
the whole thing because it's obviously
let me read one line from it if you
don't mind yeah yeah and this is Putin
speaking see what they do with their own
peoples the destruction of the family
cultural and national identity
perversion mockery of children and
pedophilia are declared the norm
now to chat I'm going to ask you you
know is anything he says wrong is
anything in that statement wrong
okay you don't have to be a believer
because you know Putin uh says that he's
a a Believer you know in in Christianity
and that's very respectable but you
don't have to be a believer to to uh to
read that and say [__] he's absolutely
right you know but if he is now the norm
in the west you know of course they
don't call it pedophilia anymore they
call it minor attracted person or minor
attraction to people Jesus Christ yeah
whenever you see that map in in the bio
of somebody on Twitter you know what
you're dealing with you're dealing with
pero yeah we've got we've got um you
know cross-dressing [__] or whatever
they are you know reading books to kids
in schools and it's all being celebrated
and they're forced to clap over the
whole thing it's it's just a bizarity
what did you think of the whole uh I
mean it's a two-minute video
um I'm sure there's a lot more to it but
that seemed to be like the Highlight
Reel he was talking about we must
protect our children the Anglican Church
for example considers the idea of gender
neutral God this was a recent
announcement from England forgive us
Lord for they know for they don't know
what they do look at Holy scriptures the
family is a union of a man and a woman
so he touches on a lot of these
sensitive points I mean like what do you
think of the State of the Union speech
that Putin you know recently made like
what do you think was behind that well
no it was just a a state of the nation
speech it was an hour and 45 minutes
long I watched the whole thing and most
of it was devoted to domestic stuff and
domestic programs that are going to be
implemented and by the way a lot of
these uh domestic programs have gotten a
very very positive response in Russia
like for instance one of the things that
he's gonna is doing
is that any family that has two children
or more are not going to pay property
tax
that's a big deal in in Russia because
when you when you have property tax that
you have to pay ongoing and also when
you uh sell a property in less than five
years since you purchased it you also
have to pay 13 I believe and those taxes
are going to be rescinded for families
that have two or more children clearly
you know they're they're aiming to
improve their demographics by way of
incentives is something that the
hungarians are doing and very
effectively by the way of improving
their demographics by way of the state
giving incentives to families to have
more children
um you know longer longer maternity
leads you know that kind of stuff he
also talked very specifically in great
detail about uh programs that they're
going to do for returning veterans you
know uh psychological uh assistance work
assistance you know that sort of thing
um the the domestic uh programs package
was the bulk of the speech insofar as
the rest of the world is concerned the
the big highlight wasn't really the
cultural stuff that he talked about and
that was sort of like a jab to the west
but and sort of like a reminder as to
what the West represents in the eyes of
the rest of the world because you know
all this we kind of like laugh and and
just are kind of like horrified by the
pedo stuff and the and the trans stuff
in the west but in the rest of the world
they look at this as just decadence and
degeneracy they're horrified by it they
want no part of it and they say well if
if to be part of the West we have to get
on board with this [__] [__] that I
mean they're very serious about it for
the vast majority of people in the
Middle East in Africa in Asia in Latin
America Central America all that stuff
of of trans and and wokeness and all
that [__] is horrifying and they want no
piece of it none of I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here here that clips from
if you're new to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out